[Musique]
bonjour daniel marie-sainte bonjour
secrétaire national à l'organisation du
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
merci d'être avec nous dans son caddie
question toute simple daniel
marie-sainte comment se porte le minent
mais comme d'habitude il fonctionne
dites nous comment vous percevez selon
vous un la vision que peuvent avoir les
martiniquais de votre formation
politique
je ne sais pas en tout cas c'est une
organisation qui existe depuis
maintenant quelques années
ouais nous n'avons été grillés si votre
mémoire 78 un petit petit une
organisation qui a pris naissance dans
les racines sont plantés à
rivière-pilote et qui progressivement
céder vos clés sur l'ensemble du pays en
phase d'expansion toujours selon vous
vous avez atteint un certain niveau
en tout cas moi mon ambition c'est
continuer à implanter des comités
patriotes dans toutes les communes en
tout cas quand j'ai été nommé au poste
secrétaire l'organisation c'est un peu
la ligne qui m'a été donnée
implanté décapité patriotes dans toutes
les communes de l'île
malo nîmes parti au pouvoir parti shas
uti daniel marie-sainte en interne des
militants des soldats des purs jus du
mime se plaignent première revendication
on ne sait pas tirer des leçons de ce
qui se passe exemple le plus flagrant
à ce jour zéro débriefing des
législatives
vous dites quoi ces militants qui sont
mécontents et en tout cas je n'ai pas
l'habitude de le discuter des affaires
intérieures du mime sur les médias nous
avons des lieux entre nous nous
discutons nous analysons avait beaucoup
de forte personnalité parce que pour
être au mime
il faut avoir une forte personnalité
pour est indépendantiste patriotes dans
un pays colonisé il va votre
personnalité donc le regret que nous
avons les débats intenses mais nous
avons des liens suffisants ils disent
c'est un lieu où on discute ensemble ils
seront pas seuls dans les médias a tous
eu tout cela sera fait lors d'un
séminaire prévu au début du mois de
novembre vous dis que je ne discute pas
les questions du mime un terme sur les
médias ont je vais pas vous confondez
deux parties nous avons des lieux nous
nous rencontrons nous discutons et nous
chercher au fond un consensus entre nous
et deux jours comme ça que nous avons
fonctionné et c'est justement ça fait
pas un peu vivre cette façon de faire
impossible en tout cas c'est notre
manière à nous et vous êtes
d'accord c'est des militants se
plaignent de cette façon de fonctionner
je vous dis que je le suis pas sur les
médias
vous savez les militants et nous il ya
un risque d'implosion des volumes et où
le dit aurait coûté splendeur qui ont
même écrit une lettre
notamment lors des dix l'atv lorsqu'il
s'agissait de savoir qui serait candidat
dans la circonscription du centre
voulaient rencontrer ces frondeurs
je ne connais je reconnais pas ce type
ce terme vous parler des élections bien
nous avons présenté un candidat du mime
qui s'appelle jean philippe lors et qui
a été brillamment réélue dans le sud est
ça le candidat du mime n'avions pas
d'autre candidat lui même oui mais on
vous demande de faire des débriefings de
situation parce que lisa qui fait
s'acquitter pour fait sa kippa fait ça
qu'ils regrettaient pour fait sa kippa
vous faites encore et militons vie
d'entendre les applique à tout le monde
comment ça fonctionne nous avons un
comité national qui se réunit
nous avons un conseil national où les
militants débattre il ya les
contradictions ne les résolvons par la
discussion allait fonctionner et puis
plusieurs communes actuellement dans 17
communes nous avons des capés qui sont
en contact directement avec le peuple
voilà le fonctionnement du mime
maintenant qu'il y ait des débats c'est
la vie même le parti
les débats au sein d'un parti se se
solutionne se résolvent par la
discussion
on est tous à droite c'est bien la betty
à la rubrique nos activités des regards
extérieurs n'est pas une question de
regard extérieur
c'est une question de mode de résolution
de problème donc nous discutons de
renault depuis la création du mime
ç'a toujours été la méthode et la
semaine et nous ne sommes jamais nous
sommes jamais allés dans les médias pour
étaler nos débats internes
parce que c'est pas ça la vie de notre
organisation dont pour vous la seule
réunion mensuelle du site du mime ccc
c'est ce cette réunion qui permet de
désamorcer les crises de ces la soupape
qui permet d'évaluer cette intention
question s'appelle la résolution les
contradictions et les contradictions
partout et c'est la manière de résoudre
les collections c'est parce que comme
nous sommes des amis politiques nous
avaient le même idéal politique de faire
nous un peuple responsable de conquérir
notre souveraineté
il ya donc des contradictions dans tout
groupe humain je ne dis pas qu'il ya des
contradictions mais c'est dans la nature
même des choses donc nous discutons
on a notre cher l'adversaire la loi sera
votre mode de fonctionnement ce manège
et parlons de parler de l'avenir du mime
à ce mouvement indépendantiste
martiniquais doit-il opérer une mutation
renouvellement quittera même de plus en
plus exigée par limitant à tout cas
l'avenir d'une jeune âge ce que les
militants du mouvement
levine a été créé par une génération
alors le relais en train de se passer
nous avons nous mêmes notre comité
national nous avons voulu toujours quand
l'hymne national la banque qui est la
parité moitié homme moitié femme et gm a
répété les trois générations va dire les
anciens ceux qui à peu prendre un bel
moyens et puis les jeunes qui prennent
la relève et jean louis tremblay h
moyens il est jeune il a intégré de
l'organisation il représentait
d'ailleurs les jeunes maintenant eu là
bas il y en a d'autres qui le relève
c'est ça la venue en lui et qu'attend
t'on pour lui confier les rênes du parti
vu les conditions de sa réélection est
ce qu'on en parle
ce sera un des thèmes des femmes en dire
plus ce serait non mais c'est pas ça
c'est la question à si la question se
pose aujourd'hui à l'intérieur et de
l'extérieur alors vous l'entendez daniel
marie-sainte nous débattons nous nous
débattons la divine nous entendons ce
que vous en pensez vous est ce que je ne
fais ni noirs et leurs poursuivants
immédiats mais non mais je ne fais pas
et assure les médias les débats qui sont
internés jeu d'ailleurs j'ai toujours
demandé à tous les militants concentrons
nous d'abord pour porter l'information
l'éducation politique au peuple à
l'extérieur rapporté verre chaud
mais les militants qui sont devenus élus
nous avons des élus municipaux nous
avons des élus conseil territorial à la
au choléra collectivités territoriales
donc nous avons besoin et des trois dans
l'osmose pour d'abord savoir ce que
pense le peuple ce qu'ils ont besoin nos
militants doivent également diffuser
toutes ces informations
et puis pour faire fonctionner de
l'organisation nous avons des structures
où nous discute entre nous nous
améliorons la risée des anciens du mime
sommes d'accord mais que pensez-vous de
jean-philippe ni lors il est trop
gentille en corrèze était déjà pour moi
je les ai déjà dit ici ip accueille jean
philippe sella venir le même c'est la
manière de même c'est notre porte parole
au sein de l'assemblée des députés de
france c'est le porte parole
en france les avis du gouvernement donc
et jean philippe est en est le président
le chef du groupe de grands ensembles et
booba pays riches ans à l'intérieur la
collectivité territoriale jean-philippe
vient d'être réélu brillamment dans le
sud dont jean-philippe ou mois et
toujours dit ça en interne et ex à
l'extérieur celle à venir nombreux
mouvements nous avons la chance de labro
jean-philippe donc notre disque de
sensibilisation sur le tri version du
mobile
pardon ils risquent de se sentir un peu
seul il ya d'autres personnes derrière
lui et à tous le mda lui de la mine le
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
on vous reproche de n'être
indépendantistes dans votre comme dans
l'appellation de votre mouvement
dans cette forêt nous avons un texte
fondamental n'est pas si étonnant de
repos mais déjà qui est de la ration de
1991 c'est lui qui a fondé la période de
transition pour lequel le second vient
de vivre
nous avions fait un croche-patte lonely
tunes colonies dominé économiquement
occupé militairement et qui n'avait aps
le disposez pas là sur
l'autodétermination nous avions souhaité
et ça a progressé qu'ils puissent avoir
une consultation référendaire n'était
pas référendaire mais ya eu la
consultation où le peuple martiniquais
tout seul parce que c'est nous qui avons
fait évoluer la constitution française
s'en souvient pour que ce soit seulement
les électeurs martiniquais qui l'horizon
pour l'avenir est ce que vous regrettez
en 2003 qui est une première
consultation 2010 une seconde
actuellement de la collectivité unique
nous l'avions à l'époque où est la mieux
une assemblée la limite les choix se
font tout doucement mais oui parce que
il faut faire l'apprentissage la
stabilité met en confiance parce qu'on
disait que nous soyons pas gérer nous
étions des irresponsables il fallait
mettre en confiance la confiance du
peuple que vous savez gérer
nous travaillons pour l'étape historique
quant à ses abonnés savons pas mais non
une des tables historique où la question
sera posée dans 90 des cas elles n'ont
comme les catalans ça vous fait envie
cette situation qatalum d'avoir contre
le peuple catalan non nous applaudissons
ceux qui ont le courage de dire nous
faisons nous autodéterminer nous
travaillons à l'éducation du peuple que
nous ayons confiance en ont déjà
vous avez eu le réflexe populaire que
nous n'avons plus crier à quelques uns
des problèmes entier qu'on se retourne
la cdm on a va plus pleurer à la
préfecture ou pleurer auprès de l'état
etc
c'était pour aller vers la conscience
maintenant il faut que nous les ayons
les moyens de répondre à toutes les
demandes
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nos
daniel marie-sainte on rappelle que le
secrétaire national à l'organisation du
mime merci bonjour je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]